بعد عامين من القيود الوبائية ،
يعود سوق الماشية هذا في اسطنبول إلى الحياة ، إنه
عيد التضحية الإسلامي في الوقت
الذي يشتري فيه المسلمون
ويذبحون الأغنام والماشية ويتقاسمون
اللحوم مع المحتاجين ،
إنه مشهد حيوي مع المشترين
والبائعين  إن المساومة
وإبرام الصفقات
على الرغم من الابتهاج الذي يجعل حالة
اقتصاد تركيا تجعل من الصعب
الاحتفال مع ارتفاع التضخم ،
يقول البائعون إنهم يكافحون من أجل الاستمرار
في
إطعامهم باهظ التكلفة.
نحن ندفع
مقابل هذا المكان الذي
يزداد صعوبة ، يقول إن
تكلفة الخروف المتوسط ​​هذا العام
تبلغ حوالي 4000 ليرة تركية أي حوالي
دولارًا أمريكيًا في بلد حيث
الحد الأدنى للأجور يعادل ما يزيد قليلاً عن
300 دولار أمريكي مما يجعل هذا شيئًا
يمكن للكثيرين  لا يتحمل
أردوغان غوك هذا العام مع
أحفاده لشراء خروف ،
إنه تقليد يريد أن يبقى على قيد الحياة ولكن
يقول إن هذه ليست مساعدة لطيفة ، فإن ارتفاع
التكاليف لم يترك له خيارًا سوى
إغلاق عمله الأسبوع الماضي وتسريح
موظفيه العشرين
على مدار الـ 26 عامًا الماضية في عملي ،
لقد شاهدت كل أزمة يقولها ولكن
لا شيء مثل
هذا يشبه  حريق يحرق الناس
أن الحريق هو أسوأ تضخم في تركيا منذ
أكثر من 20 عامًا ، بلغ المعدل الرسمي
ما يقرب من 80 في المائة في يونيو ، لكن
يعتقد الكثيرون في الواقع أنه أعلى بكثير من
أن الحكومة رفعت الحد الأدنى للأجور
مرتين منذ ديسمبر ولكن
بتكلفة كبيرة جدًا.  كل شيء مستمر في
الارتفاع يقول الناس إنه من المستحيل الحفاظ
على تكلفة المواد الغذائية اليومية التي
تضاعفت تقريبًا في عام واحد مما يجعل
المسرات الحلوة التقليدية للمساعدات بعيدة
المنال بالنسبة للكثيرين
تقول إن عائلتها سيتعين عليها التخلي عن
صينية البقلاوة التقليدية هذا العام
إنهم بالكاد يستطيعون تحمل الضروريات
هذه الأيام
يخبرنا هذا الزوجان أن التكاليف الباهظة قد
سلبت متعة التسوق في عدم وجود
ملابس جديدة للأطفال هذا
العام فقط  لكن الجزء الأصعب بالنسبة
لهؤلاء المسلمين المتدينين هو عدم قدرتهم
على تحمل تكلفة الخروف للتضحية
بتكاليف الطاقة العالمية المتزايدة للحرب في
أوكرانيا وفقدان الليرة التركية
حوالي نصف قيمتها في العام الماضي ،
كل ذلك ساهم في ارتفاع التضخم
لكن الاقتصاديين لعبوا الكثير.  فيما يتعلق
بالسياسات الاقتصادية غير التقليدية للرئيس التركي ، يرفض أردوغان رفع
أسعار الفائدة لمحاربة التضخم ،
بل إنه تعهد بخفض أسعار الفائدة أكثر من
هذا ، البالغ من العمر 29 عامًا ، ويخبرنا أنه لا يملك سوى ما
يكفي لشراء أحذية مستعملة للمساعدة.
غدًا سيكون ستة يقول
من المسؤول ،
دعونا لا نتحدث عن أن
قلة سيتحدثون عن من يلومونهم
ومن المحتمل أن يأخذوا شكاواهم إلى
صناديق الاقتراع العام المقبل وقد يكلف ذلك
الرئيس ،
لكن في الوقت الحالي ، سيستمر الأتراك العاديون
في تحمل  العبء الأكبر من هذا
الاقتصاد المضطرب gemani karachi cnn
istanbul